house we'll make a separate second
attempt today to vote to repeal
Obamacare this time Republicans he to
say the bill what bill will not fail
President Trump and his congressional
allies agreed to add billions of dollars
in funding to their health care
legislation that chain persuaded some
Republicans to ship from no to yes those
members say the added money will protect
patients with pre-existing conditions it
did not persuade the House Democratic
Leader Nancy Pelosi who calls the bill a
moral monstrosity Nancy Cordes is on
Capitol Hill with the countdown to
today's vote Nancy good morning good
morning after weeks of uncertainty and
cajoling and negotiating Republican
leaders now say they have the requisite
support from within their own party to
pass this health care bill today
Democrats argue it's being rushed
through without key details from the
Congressional Budget Office about how
much it will cost and what the impact
will be on people with pre-existing
conditions we need a CBO score
republicans and democrats clashed in a
late-night session paving the way for
today's vote this process to put a
bluntly zhurko mess because we have
enough votes it's a good bill GOP
leaders and the vice president have
spent the past three days leaning hard
on undecided Republicans how many people
have changed their votes from no to yes
they've been a number I'm not gonna get
into the details some holdouts were
swayed by last-minute tweaks to the bill
I'm happy to announce that the people in
the seventh District of Missouri will
have pre-existing conditions covered
adequately with this edition that we
just talked to president Intel the GOP
plan would reduce Obamacare's subsidies
for lower-income Americans and eliminate
taxes on the wealthy used to pay for
them instead people making less than
$75,000 a year would get age based tax
credits the bill seeks to lower premiums
by allowing states to opt out of Obama
cares minimum coverage rules which
require insurers to cover things like
maternity care and emergency services
states could also allow insurers to
charge higher rates for some with
pre-existing conditions but only if
those states set up high-risk pools to
help people afford it
this is
of a fig leaf to try and win people over
Democrats argue that plan has been
panned by most major interest groups
including the American Medical
Association the AARP and the American
Cancer Society republicans argue
Obamacare has its own problems with
insurance providers pulling out almost
every month but what's going to happen
if Congress does nothing when you've got
states like Iowa that might end up with
no insurers in the individual it's up to
it's up to the Trump administration once
they can't pass a bill to work with us
to improve Obamacare the most recent
analysis we have from the Congressional
Budget Office a couple of months ago was
that 24 million fewer Americans would
have insurance under this bill we don't
know if this analysis would change based
on new versions of the bill but
Republicans argue that the analysis is
flawed and they have been encouraging
their members to vote yes saying that
the bill is going to undergo major
changes in the Senate anyway Gale all
right Nancy we will all be watching
thank you